you remember the first time you could
ever ejaculate or no
i'm trying i don't think i remember the
first time i ever ejaculated what
oh
bro well i had sex before i ever
masturbated oh
yeah
i i started masturbating after i had sex
no way man i don't know if that happens
to a lot of people that's pretty rare oh
my god dude and then after i had a
girlfriend and started fooling around
then i realized like how dependent
on her i was for that feeling for sex
because you know when you're 15 16 years
old like you are so horny like all the
time it's like you're aching it's
horrific do you remember those days
yeah i do you get those steel boners
that just controlled your life
like a compass due north
i remember opening my pants to pee and i
would hear
peeing out of a bone or just hot peeing
sideways in a freaking
thing just
well put your hand on the wall and bend
towards it like you're [ __ ] and then
try to hold yourself up with one hand
and push your boner down with your other
hand yeah yeah like push it down like
you're trying to force a drunk out of a
bar
[Laughter]
dude i remember when i could first of
jack and later i remember they had this
lady i'd go outside in the morning and
i'm gonna jerk off outside and they had
this lady that would walk these two dogs
right and so the because i remember
seeing on nature channel where if like
there's urine or animal semen like some
animals won't it's like territory right
so i remember uh
she would walk these two dogs and i
would do it in like different spots to
see if the animal like what they would
do like a reaction
and uh the little one would go over
there and the big one would never even
really yeah it was like the little one i
guess almost felt like a cuck
yeah yeah
yeah you want to go over to sniff your
loads
but the big one didn't want that smoke
baby
[Laughter]
but i remember that dude yeah it was so
exciting i remember here's one thing i
do really
really uh recollect emotionally was
that i had this thing that made me feel
good i could feel good whenever i wanted
to
and that was a huge thing for me yeah
like if i was having a horrible day or i
was thinking you know was not feeling
good about myself which was a lot as a
kid
i could come home and i could bust one
and make my it was suddenly i had
control over how i felt right and it was
the only way to do it and it was this uh
which is probably not a great way to to
establish feeling decent you know
but uh
but suddenly i had that little decent
stick on me here you know what i used it
for a sleeping pill
it was great if i couldn't sleep whack
one off
i could see that for you out cold i
could see that right here we go
like if i need to take a nap and i know
i only have like an hour i'm like well
15 minutes if it'll be me beating off
and then i'll definitely get that 45 in
otherwise i'm laying there for a [ __ ]
35 minutes going if i go to sleep now i
get 15 minutes [ __ ] if i go to sleep now
i can sleep for 10 minutes
i bust a nut then i'm going to sleep
right away oh no if ands or butts i'm
snoring i'm sucking on my own tongue at
that point i'm out yeah
um yeah i remember it was fun dude that
was fun being just those just the busts
were just like
oh
beautiful i remember when i was 16 years
old it was like one of the
first times uh a girl would ever give me
a blow job this girl's dating gave me a
blow job and i inside uh outside on a
porch yeah at night time um girls dating
and uh
i came so hard my ears rang
the only time in my life it was like
[Music]
and i was lightheaded i was like jesus
because those were like 16 year old
shots that's a different thing
when you you've been just storing it up
for a few weeks
it was like watching the like those guys
would go off that thing on the olympics
it was like that too just
skiers
yeah
[Laughter]
oh man that was fun dude you know what's
really crazy is that you think about the
difference between being 11
12 and then 13
14 15 16. in just
five years
your
desire like what you want to do with the
world
changes
a hundred percent all sudden you've got
all these crazy hormones in your system
you're confused you're hard all the time
like you get boners in class all the
time i'd have to pull out my shirt like
if you sat down too long you'd get a
boner we have to walk up to the board
backwards and [ __ ] like just weird [ __ ]
or you would tuck it into like the the
top yeah it's almost like you'd be
poking wear a big shirt for your
underwear wear a lamaze shirt from your
stepmom if you're if you have a heart on
and it's like this you got a problem but
if you take it and you put it like that
yeah and put that you lock it lock it in
with that rub the rubber from the the
underwear band
and it's like he's poking out of the top
they put the clothes over it like
nothing to see here put it in that hard
scarf baby you know what i'm saying
that's your next invention joe rogan's
teenage boner lock underwear do you know
elvis had a boner in a movie
there was a movie i believe it something
some movie with women i forget what it's
called women are in the title but
there's a scene where elvis is with this
girl and she's pretty [ __ ] hot and
elvis is uh like dancing with her and
he's got a full rod like it's poking out
of his pants and they left it in there
damn they didn't even cut around it
so now when i get real excited even
still i'll grab my penis and squeeze it
do you ever do that
when it's hard or soft when it's soft
you just grab it yeah like it makes like
a [ __ ]
no it's just like you're saying
like let me think i don't like to
squeeze it when it's soft it hurts yeah
it makes her feel kind of fired up so
elvis in this scene yeah
the walls have ears look at that
got him full damn back that up a little
bit
daddy running that rod out there watch
this as he moves watch this
watch this right there bro
he's got a boner that's that 11 pound
test look at him look how she backs her
her vagina back like yes she realizes
something's going on there immediately
bro women were different back then
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one